questa sera vi voglio raccontare come
funziona come fatta questa macchina cosa
che non ho mai provato un audience di
questo genere
questa che vedete lei vi sta davanti è
stata disegnata da mario bellini
comunque la sua esistenza la dobbiamo
alcuni personaggi che voglio ringraziare
pubblicamente qui cominciando da questo
no no no no non oil nonoil comando
frugiate comunque per descrivere quello
che vi racconterò e come funziona la
programma 101 e poi arriverò a farvi
vedere come si può utilizzarla così
semplice che sono sicuro che riuscirete
a capirla al volo allora devo
ringraziare il adriano olivetti come
primo mario giù e roberto olivetti che
hanno costruito quello che io chiamo la
valle dell'eden perché della conoscenze
informatiche di quel tempo la parola
informatica ancora non era conosciuta e
poi naturalmente il pier giorgio perotto
che ci ha pilotato alla sua
realizzazione a mandarla in produzione
a questo punto vediamo questo era il
gruppettino di per giorgio perotto
questa è la tastiera della macchina di
allora una macchina numerica e il
linguaggio che a questa macchina un
linguaggio simbolico cosa vuol dire che
ogni istituzione ogni comando a un
simbolo a un solo tasto pigiando quel
tasto si genera un codice dalla tastiera
che va direttamente in memoria senza
bisogno di nessuna traduzione io
normalmente quando mi vengono a trovare
i ragazzi delle scuole del liceo che
fanno la loro gita da noi
il museo tecnologicamente d'ivrea uso
questa pagina perché basta per
descrivere la macchina e adesso comincio
se avete un attimo di pazienza che io
porto avanti questa mia pazza idea
pazza idea allora sulla sinistra è
descritta schermata in modo molto
schematico quello che è la macchina
la macchina è costituita da 10 registri
rappresentati da queste scatoline p1 p2
e poi mr b c d e f sono dieci registi di
24 caratteri 24 by tutta la macchina è
di fatto costituita da 200 e 40 byte
meno di un quarto di k questo perché
possiate fare i conti del rapporto fra
questa macchina e quelle che sono le
macchine di oggi i registri sono p1 e p2
solo di programma il programma
quando si comincia a inserire comincia a
occupare prima p1xx quattro caratteri
poi pidoux altri 24 caratteri se ho più
di quarantotto istruzioni devo invader
registro f registro è registro di il
massimo numero di istruzioni di 120
istruzioni gli altri registi
quell'indirizzo abili sono come ho detto
mr b c d e f
tre sono i registri operativi m a ed r m
il registro che riceva i dati i numeri
dalla tastiera e oa il secondo operando
di una operazione adoperando a è il
primo operando o il risultato si forma
in a r un registro di appoggio e di
fatto dopo la divisione a il resto pcdf
sono numerici possono usarli o interi
oppure con due numeri dentro indicando
la seconda meta che si batte con il
tasto split che è un tasto della
tastiera
questa è la macchina adesso proviamo a
guardare quello che è il linguaggio il
linguaggio è un linguaggio di 15
istruzioni 15 codifica su 4 bit ne
abbiamo addirittura un codice
risparmiato perché con 4 bit si fanno
sede di configurazioni le istruzioni
sono semplicissimi molto intuitive e
come già ad esempio la istruzione s o
start stop
l'istituzione col codice zero quando il
programma si trova la macchina si ferma
libera tastiera possa introdurre i
numeri poi o tre istruzioni che servono
a movimentare i dati freccia in su che
vuol dire coppia il registro m che
quello grecia dalla tastiera nel
all'indirizzo che io ti dico l'indirizzo
che accompagna sempre l'istruzione
freccia in giù è o richiamo è quello che
copia il registro indirizzato nella
cumulato re come prima operando poi
visto che queste copie mi fanno perdere
sempre un dato abbiamo messo anche la
doppia freccia o scambio scambia al volo
ha con gli altri registri poi abbiamo le
quattro operazioni a due operandi che
fanno copiare l'indirizzo come secondo
operando e poi operano a ed m
il risultato va in una sola istruzione
con un solo operaio della radice
quadrata fa la radice quadrata via po il
output stampa e stampa e azzera poi
quelli un po più difficili
abbiate un attimo di pazienza soltanto
sono vw y z sono quelli che servono per
controllare la sequenza di programma in
particolare funzionano quando io trovo
l'istruzione di salto va a cercare un
suo riferimento in particolare questa
codifica viene fatta utilizzando al
campo indirizzi in particolare
l'indirizzo è meno l'indirizzo
praticamente implicito m va a cercare
l'indirizzo a cioè se io schiaccio sa se
io schiaccia il tasto voi salto vado
accertare il codice a v detto questo
praticamente la macchina è illustrata
completamente
adesso vi faccio vedere quanto sia
facile
assegnare delle funzioni ai quattro
tasti di salto che io posso digitare
dalla tastiera accendo la macchina
intanto la macchina normalmente lavora
come una calcolatrice usa la notazione
polacca inversa quindi non al uguale ma
io introduco il primo operando faccio
l'inter che è la freccia e gli faccio il
secondo operando chiasso il comando ad
esempio di per in questo caso la
macchina opera mi faccio sentire anche
la radice quadrata di due con 15
decimali
ecco e il suo rumore caratteristico a
questo
a questo punto vi faccio vedere quanto
sia facile introdurre assegnare a questi
tasti un programmino fatto molto
semplice
allora abbiamo visto che il riferimento
del tasto vw devo mettere a questo punto
il carica programma lo stato di carica
programma quello che adesso digito non
viene eseguito ma viene accumulato come
una successione di istruzione che
costituiscono il programma allora av è
il mio riferimento del tasto v
faccio il mio numero lo introdotto da
tastiera quindi nel registro m
faccio l'inter lo quindi copiato in a
se faccio il per in a o il quadrato se
faccio un'altra volta il per in a o
incubo a segno questa istruzione al
tasto b
e mi fermo a questo punto fate lo stesso
lavoro con il tasto w4 lenta
faccio il quadrato faccio il cubo lo
stanze thabo mi fermo lo faccio col
tasto y lanter il quadrato
il cubo la quarta potenza alla stampa e
mi fermo a me ma faccio l'ultimo già che
ci sono la z faccio l'interfaccia il
quadrato faccio il cubo la quarta la
quinta e la sesta la star forlì fermo a
questo punto dico faccio il 6 salva
salvo no state attenti al linguaggio
perché il linguaggio questa è una
macchina al 65 ma adesso vedete che è lo
stesso linguaggio
a questo punto tolgo in carica programma
io provo fare due alla quarta nomi non
mi obbedisce la macchina no no affatto
ha fatto tutto eccolo qua faccio tre
alla quinta la macchina funziona mi fa
le operazioni se la vedete
eccoli a questo punto però faccio io
cancello tutto spingo anche alla
macchina la vicenda
faccio il reset la macchina in effetti
non mi fa più nulla
però io ho la mia ap la mia viva faccio
allora seguite al linguaggio faccio il
download dell'app si apre si apre una
finestra si apre la windows
io vedo un icona schiaccio l'icona è la
mia macchina esegue la mia ap
ho voluto usare il linguaggio perché
questo adesso 65 allora non c'erano
queste parole però guarda caso i
concetti sono quelli sono gli stessi
sono rimasti uguali ad allora non solo
ma questa macchina usa le immagini non
c'ha il mouse launch al monitor ma usa
le immagini l'icona fatti un clic
sull'icona e la macchina esegue la mia
up ho detto ho detto apre no come il mio
amico graziano che mi ha fatto vedere il
suo navigatore che era uguale al mio
dice guarda che bello
io ho detto ma il mio non la fa questa
roba qui lui dice certo ci devi mettere
la pipì io sono scompisciato da ridere
adesso voglio vedere questa qui in
inglese come gli viene quando la
traducano ragazzi